herzlich willkommen und hallo hier aus
der maria theresien kaserne heute am
donnerstag haben wir für euch ein stab
work out vorbereitet der fokus wird ganz
klar auf der rückenmuskulatur liegen
gestern sensomotorik und gleichgewicht
heute eben wie gesagt die
rückenmuskulatur kurzer input dazu die
bauchmuskulatur das wissen wir bereits
die muss stark sein die muss kräftig
sein
aber der rücken sollte noch kräftiger
als einer der stabilisiert und in jeder
aufrechte position permanent immer und
überall
wir haben heute wieder einen spezialgast
dabei das hat die niki lauda ich der
beta event und unser spezial dass dies
die vorzugs führer olivia wohlgemuth
dritte ihm bei der europameisterschaft
im florettfechten der könnt meister den
konnex jahr stellen wir haben einen stab
und wir fechten wir bekämpfen uns nahles
nominiert
olivia du störst bitte kurz dich von
deinen sport vor wie bist du dazu
gekommen
hallo ich bin die olivia wohlgemuth bin
dem heeres sportzentrum 03 und bin zum
fechten durch meinen bruder gekommen
weil wir schon das kleine kinder mit dem
stab den fechtsport ausprobiert haben
also tochter starb kampf wie vorher
erwähnt die quasi die basis für eine
florettfechter karriere aber ich kann
nicht beruhigen wir werden heute nicht
mit dem staat kämpfen miteinander wir
werden in das trainingsunternehmen das
heißt entweder schnappen gymnastik starb
am besten stücke schnell schaffen was
halt so im umkreis ist und macht einfach
dieses workout mit uns gemeinsam mit
niki wir machen gemeinsam mit der uni
wertes werk hat wie vor am anfang mal
allgemein unternehmen stecken dazu zum
aufwärmen
[Applaus]
das heißt laufen am stand und einfach
mal schauen ein kreislauf in schwung
bringen und entsprechend in kupfer
vorbereiten training wird heute
anstrengend werden vor allem wie gesagt
für die rückenmuskulatur bis braucht man
hätte und mit dem allgemeinen aufwärmen
ist natürlich auch immer wieder auch ein
mobilisieren verbunden das heißt kurz
stehen bleiben
wir mobilisieren im bereich der
halswirbelsäule mit blick wendung links
und rechts beginnen
er ist oliver du bist über deinen bruder
zum florett fechten gekommen ist es auch
ein leistungssportler im florettfechten
oder bist du da die einzige die über
geblieben
die jahre sportzentrum ist aber
mittlerweile pensionist sportversion es
ergänzend league wendung nach oben und
nach unten
das hast du bist die die jetzt quasi die
florettfechter fahnen hochhält genau
ihnen braucht es sparringpartner dann
steht der maler gerhard kopf neigen nach
links und nach rechts hin und her kippen
wo kann man in österreich florettfechten
also bei uns gibt es in jedem bundesland
man kann überall anfang auge blickt
wendung nach links kopf rollen auf die
rechte seite über die brust das heißt
eigentlich in jedem bundesland möglich
genau das trainingsbedingungen sind gut
bei euch auf jeden fall und es kann eben
jedes alter kann beginnen
ok bewegen uns wieder kurzem stand
fangen wir mal an allgemein lockerer
kniehoch das heißt ihm bewegen mit
einbauen einmal linkes bein hoch ein
rechtes bein hoch und ist der soli wird
ein bisschen nach außen mit dem knie hat
das besondere bewandtnis bei euch da
wird mehr zeit auf anfrage weil ich
glaube dass einfach aus eurer position
heraus dieser breite stand mit beim
aufwärmen glaube dort soll mit ins spiel
kommt dass der kursrückgang probieren
die knie nach außen zu drehen und dann
entsprechend auch das bein wieder hoch
zu heben da haben wir eine für die
meisten von euch euer gewisse kreative
komponente mit dabei immer wieder zu
mobilisieren zurück schulter
mobilisieren das heißt wir fangen an
schulter kreisen vorzunehmen wenn man
nicht den ganzen arm sondern wir nehmen
nur die schultern kreisen sie vorwärts
schauen mal was man allgemein das
schultergelenk auf betriebstemperatur
bringen große kreise und rückwärts
kreisen
und das probieren wir gleich noch eine
vorwärts rückwärts gerne sehr gut
richtung wechseln und ich glaube wenn
man die schulter schauen ab titel bewegt
haben dann käme dann stecken wir zur
hand nehmen das probiere marke aus eine
rotationsbewegung mit dem mit dem stab
nicht gibt sagt mal vor bitte genau über
kopf einfach den staat nach hinten
bringen mit einer hand und über die
andere hand wieder nach vor
wichtig dabei auch hier darf auch der
rücken die rumpfmuskulatur im
allgemeinen bleibt unter spannung dass
man da wohl kreuzen einkommen und die
beweglichkeit der wirbelsäule jetzt
kommt sondern hauptsächlich eben aus der
schulter auch einmal die richtung
wechseln und das ist so wie bei jedem
training bei jedem workout dir um
stabilität die muss immer gegeben sein
haben sie da eine vorspannung beim
fechten die hände und jetzt aber auch
mal eine übung die kennziffer von
unserem theraband work hat das heißt
greift einmal relativ breit am stab und
versuchte mir ohne den griff zu lösen
die schultern nach hinten zu bewegen die
arme nach hinten zu bewegen und die
schultern zu drehen aber bitte wirklich
nur so schmal greifen so dass wir keine
verletzungen haben sondern dass man
einen titel beweglichkeit und mobilität
in der schule mit trainieren
der wechsel mal drei vier fünf mal hin
und her
genauer ok starb bitte wieder zur seite
geben
dann sprechen wir mal runter hampelmann
hätte gesagt zum aktivieren zum
warmwerden der muskulatur stromspannung
ist bei euch im täglichen training mit
dabei
auf jeden fall jacke sowie bei uns bei
den soldaten da wir darum spannung das
ganze die die kraft aus dem raum voraus
annähernd täglich trainiert weil jede
zusatzbelastung die man damit trägt
rucksack bewaffnung was er immer ist
natürlich eine große belastung als zu
stabilisieren und die rumpfmuskulatur
natürlich genauso stark mit wechsel nach
vorne ausfallschritt mit handwechsel ok
kurz aus lockenstab zu hantieren aus dem
oberkörper aus fixiert mal die hände
überm kopf das heißt wir haben schon mal
große spannungen im rücken und dem bauch
trainern dass man nicht in eine
hohlkreuz position verein und dreimal
den körper nach links und nach rechts
mobilisieren wir im bereich der
wirbelsäule und mit dem stab geht das
ganze bis einfacher wenn man nur die
hände nach oben streckt er hat noch was
zum anhalten und das anhalten
funktioniert dann meistens viel besser
das ganze kann man natürlich auch in der
vorbeuge machen das heißt einmal nach
vorbeugend selber rotation noch einmal
genau
und wieder ausloggen märkte der rhythmus
schon arbeiten oder unterspannung ist ja
das heißt das ist das was das training
begleiten wird diese spannung den rücken
und die kraft die man entwickeln können
ok bewegen wir uns namen stecken kein
spiel in kens nein der hand lassen wir
das lieber haupt genau nach meinem stand
boxer laufen immer gleich dazu das heißt
auf jeden schritt eine hand ich sehe du
hast unsere videos anstatt ich kann dich
nicht überraschen mit boxer love herbst
in die werke faust macht die nicht
die nici sowie soja war die olivia hat
die workouts zu hause schon vor geübt
immer den mit den anderen
leistungssportlern gemacht haben das
erst mal auf ich konnte sie nicht mehr
überraschend funktioniert sehr gut
ok dann locker man mir aus kreis man mal
in der hüfte das heißt hände in die
hüfte stecken strecken nach links und
nach rechtskreisen wärme die seite
wechseln
gerne wandern gleich ein gelenk nach
unten auf kniegelenk bleiben wir die
eine sind gut hilft breiten stand hände
auf die kniescheibe kreisen in eine
richtung und in der anderen richtung
gerne kurz aus lockern wir heben das
linke bein hoch und kreisen im
sprunggelenk zur gleichgewichts
fähigkeit und sowas sollte eigentlich
für den fechtsport wichtig sein oder
braucht sie das weniger dort brauchen
wir schon ist ganz wichtig leider bin
ich da eher schlechter
dann ist es ja eben für die ich auch
nicht sehr gut seite wechseln anderes
beim hochheben und die richtung wechseln
und wieder ausloggen nachdem er wie
gesagt intensiv arbeiten werden müssen
wir noch mal kurz gas geben das heißt
jetzt der bewegung stand lauf start
schnell laufen auf stop langsam
weiterlaufen okay geht schloss natürlich
auch start schnell hohes tempo ist ein
hohes tempo ist einfach normal
weiterlaufen
statt
ein stopp und einmal machen wir das
ganze stadt frau stoffwechsel position
liegestütz ausstellung marco gerber beim
start noch fünf sekunden stop stehen 40
bereit und liebe für sie bereit für uns
schon gas geben für unsere stärke aber
übung der die gern von tina wissen zum
aufwärmen was macht jedem aufwärmen was
ist florett spezifisch also bei uns ist
die feststellung so und wir müssen eben
viel die ausfälle machen
unter kens glashaus eben das mal
ausprobiert auf beide seiten oder macht
es nur verein also wir machen hauptsache
auf der seite wo wir vechta
aber man kann die andere als zeit die
anderen auch machen dann würde
vorschlagen
fünf mal links fünf mal rechts
ausfallschritte aus dem flur echt blöd
sport geht schon los
wichtig dabei es möglichst elegant dabei
aus zu sehen ja dass das allerwichtigste
genau wer die fünf auf der einen seite
hat wechselt auf die zweite seite gleich
selbständig
und ich glaube mit einer florett
spezifischen übung jetzt einmal richtig
bereit fürs training
okay das was wir jetzt mit euch machen
sind 30 sekunden und belastungs zeit
immer einem wechsel an mein rücken übung
dann vielleicht einmal eine übung im
bauch übung fokus wird aber am rücken
liegen das heißt 30 sekunden belasten
30 sekunden pause und so wie die letzten
male auch schon wer möchte kann
natürlich die minute auch durch arbeiten
wir nehmen die zweiten 30 sekunden dann
immer als zeit anhalt für euch ja um
etwas zu erklären euch was zu zeigen was
man die wichtigen punkte auf die immer
bei der übung aufpassen muss das heißt
wir haben mobilisiert wir haben
aufgewärmt befangen mit der ersten
übungen mit dem land zog mit dem stab
bitte einmal in die opposition erkennt
die übung schon von einem der
vergangenen weltcup mit dem staat machen
was jetzt da wirklich etwas
authentischer nodes hier geht es in eine
schräglage in eine vorlage des
oberkörpers streckt die arme über den
kopf aus und zieht dann entweder die
stange vor dem kopf unter oder wenn es
die beweglichkeit zulässt auch hinter
dem kopf runter so dass aber die heiß
wie visuelle in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule bleibt das heißt im
natürlichen verlauf weiter geht der kopf
nicht geneigt werden muss das heißt
entsprechend stabil bleibt okay ganz
kurz nur auslagern
ihr macht euch bereit ersatz bereit
und dann würde ich vorschlagen fangen
wir in 10 sekunden mit der ersten übung
am wo geht es ganz schnell wo geht
sportlich die reise hin was ist die
nächste zielsetzung und in dieser spiele
ganz kleinen haus die qualifikation also
bei uns ist in ende märz in doha der
nächste weltcup und dann gibt es so
nicht und da gibt es eben leider noch
keinen genauen termin okay heute dafür
verhandele
ok dann hätte gesagt legen wir los 30
sekunden der lastzug im knien mitmachen
beim aktion der kämpfe die erste stammen
aus dem rücken auf da geht schon mal
richtig rund in den rückenstrecken
versuche uli wird einen heißen wirklich
gerade zu lassen genau das heißt wenn
sich der stab hinten nicht ganz runter
geht versuchen vielleicht aber vorher zu
ziehen dass man die variante drinnen hat
dass man wirklich schöne stabile
position an
genau 30 sekunden zeit vorbei wer möchte
kann natürlich gerne weiter arbeiten
30 sekunden haben wir erledigt übrigen
noch mal 2 stimmen auf genau wechseln
auf die beine
das heißt der ausfallschritt wir haben
es gut 10 ist ja spezial übung der
fechter jetzt machen wir aber die
allgemeine variante das heißt nicht das
knie und den stand beim ausdrehen
sondern schauen wir dass man eine
saubere kontrollierte beinachse haben
mit dem schritt zehenspitzen schauen
gerade noch vor das heißt ausfallschritt
stab über kopf und linkes bein nach vor
ausfallschritt probiert sagen wir vor
genoud tiefe position und wieder
zurückkommen
wem das zu schwer ist in die dynamik
hineinzugehen und wieder herauszukommen
nicht was können wir machen hier machst
du ein schritt nach vor genau arme
wieder über kopf und geht es nach unten
und nach oben dann habe ich ein bisschen
weniger dynamik drinnen ist aber genauso
anstrengend dass 30 sekunden auf hohem
tempo zu machen
das ist schon eher zu wenig wichtig ist
arme nach oben strecken geraderücken
spannung aus dem rücken heraus und er
merkt es seien nicht nur die bäume die
dort fordert werden sondern es kommt
aber rücken wieder massiv in bedrängnis
der muss arbeiten ok dann würde ich
sagen 30 sekunden arbeitszeit und los
geht's achtet auf eure beinachse das
heißt das kniegelenk bleibt in einer
ebene mit dem hüftgelenk und dem
sprunggelenk das cnnic nicht nach ihnen
das gibt nicht nach außen weg der
oberkörper bleibt aufrecht und er bleibt
in einer körperspannung aus der
rumpfmuskulatur permanent 5 sekunden und
sei dass die nächste übung machen
wechsel mal wieder ganz klassisch in den
rhythmen hinein oliver kniest ich hab
mir hin bitte so wie vorher
ausgangsposition wie beim handy über
kopf schräglage im oberkörper nach vorn
genau so gut wie es geht
und jetzt droht ihr mit eurem start der
ist ja quasi eine verlängerung nach
links und nach rechts ja genau versucht
entlang der wir müssen möglichst gerade
zu bleiben und die rotation nur in der
wirbelsäule zu machen genau und die
rückenstrecke arbeiten schon wieder die
post bleibt stolz vorne
das heißt der rücken bleibt gerade 30
sekunden arbeitszeit geht schon los
die 20 10 sekunden vorgearbeitet machen
seit 40 konnten nichts dabei atmen nicht
vergessen und er spürt die
rückenmuskulatur wie sie arbeitet sehr
gut spürbar die muskulatur nicht kann
die übung nicht so verkehrt sein aber
sie konnten noch 521 und ausloggen ganz
wieder aufstehen namens einstecken der
mit kerzen dazu hilfe in hand beim
aufstehen genau ist natürlich auch eine
möglichkeit zweite seite ausfallschritte
wir mit links angefangen
das heißt wir mitgemacht hat jetzt die
rechte seite einmal wieder in die
dynamik hineinsteigen hände überm kopf
zweite variante in der ausfallschritt
position bleiben und den körper
beziehungsweise eine art winkel traf und
runter start 19 sie konnten ihr seid
bereit
ihr seid bereit dann hätte gesagt
spricht nichts dagegen in fünf vier drei
zwei eins los geht's
genau achtet auf die position knie soll
nicht nach vorschieben sondern der
körper geht hinunter dass das hintere
bein schon abwinkeln die beinachse und
die muskulatur ist permanent unter
spannung und stabil und gerade wenn es
in den schultern ein bisserl zu viel
jetzt die permanente position oben kann
die stange auch einmal vor die brust
nehmen beziehungsweise in den nacken
legen aber am allerbesten ist wenn er
die hände gestreckt und da wirklich
durchbeißt weil die 30 sekunden seine
show vorbei kurz aus locker vier übungen
haben bereits fünfte übung machen wir zu
einer übung für den oberarm oder das
heißt den städten haben jetzt als
hilfsmittel mit dabei liegestütz
militärisches workout er kennt sich aus
sein mit dabei in der abwandlung im
liegestütz zu marschieren heute nicht
jedoch die bieten zeigt uns das einmal
vor aus der liegestütz ausgangsstellung
wandert ihr vor den stecken nach vor und
wieder zurück das heißt eine dynamische
gestreckte variante werden wer möchte
kann natürlich immer wieder vorn und
hinten an liegestütz einbauen ist jetzt
aber nicht notwendig wir haben doch den
fokus definitiv ist auf der
rumpfmuskulatur
und das kriegt man damit ganz gut ihn in
dieser dynamik und über für dich gerade
übung für euch zu hause gehe davon aus
dass es erst dann würde ich vorschlagen
im zehn sekunden legen wieder los
ausgangs position einnehmen noch 5 3 2 1
los geht's und da achtet auf eure
position das heißt die schultern bleiben
stabil
in einer ebene mit dem gesäß mit dem
knie und mit dem sprunggelenk das heißt
die liegestütz position wird da nie
verlassen die hände die arme waren dann
ein bisserl voran zurück das ist richtig
das heißt ich habe da gewisse dynamik
drin aber ihr bleibt sie in ihrer
position stabil
zehn sekunden noch einmal durch 321 und
30 sekunden seien schon wieder vorbei
das heißt der rücken war jetzt mit
belastet aber nicht der hauptspieler
also bei den good morning es ist eher
wieder hauptverantwortlich und dann geht
es richtig zur sache nicht geht auf die
bitten dresden 90 grad zu mir ja genau
und sagst einmal die good morning sfor
in dieser war
das heißt gut hüftbreit der
schulterbreite stand wenn die
beweglichkeit natürlich in der schulter
so extrem ist also so gut ist wie jetzt
bei der nici dann schaut das ist wie
wenn der staat kerzengerade immer nach
oben schauen würde ich sage mal bleibe
mal voran in der position bei euch wird
wahrscheinlich eher so ausschauen
das ist genauso gut wird die hände sind
in verlängerung von kopf und er bewegt
sich mit gestreckten beinen nur den
rumpf auf und ab für dich auch beim will
ich verschlang aller frontaler 90 grad
danke lieber in zehn sekunden legen wir
los gut morning smit der stange es ist
jetzt der angespannte waren dafür
endlich jetzt wirft 30 sekunden nur
wichtig ist lasst die beine gestreckt
das ist im kniegelenk seitz gestreckt
dadurch kommt es wirklich schön in die
rückenmuskulatur hinein beim aufheben
und der rückenstrecke arbeitet wieder
und ist wieder voll belastet fünf
sekunden noch und sei als 30 sekunden
sind vorbei ist es fordern für rücken
niki oder sagst du ist scheider an
minute durch zu arbeiten aus deiner
einschätzung jetzt vielleicht riemann
zweiten durchgang hin
dann schauen wir uns das an ok also
nächste variante
nachdem es da noch mit dem rücken gehabt
haben wächst einmal wieder am bauch das
heißt wir machen jetzt sieht es mit
rudern kombiniert audi wird auf den
gebieten dass uns die schwierige
variante mit text das heißt die gz
opposition kommt hoch und jetzt da ist
deine füße durch die stange streckt die
beine aus genau und wieder zurück kommst
wieder hoch falls durch und wieder
zurück ok also da kurze pause weil sonst
ein 30 sekunden wir gehen ja da haben
wir super komplexe übung und die zweite
übung nicht wie manchmal die
die etwas einfacher variante wie schaut
die aus ihr geht es aber wieder in
dieser position geht es mit gleichem
stange genau vor allem zum fuß hin und
wieder zurück da ist aber weniger
belastung fürs gleichgewicht aber
genauso viel feuer auf der
bauchmuskulatur danke niki kurze pausen
kurz durchschnaufen und dann los mit
einer buchung die wirklich glaube ich
sehr anstrengend wird 30 sekunden
belastung jetzt geht's los
solltet ihr mit der schwierigen variante
natürlich anfangen und entsprechend dann
irgendwann drauf kommen noch zehn
sekunden 15 sekunden
es geht sie nicht ganz aus dann wechselt
auf die zweite variante so dass anima
gehen sieht ob es geht normalerweise
immer noch
dann macht es einfach mit 70 50 konnten
zwei drei wiederholungen sander 3 3 2 1
2 das aus 30 sekunden durch stimme auf
ausfallschritte haben wir gemacht
kniebeugen sind die nächste übung
kombination mit den armen über kopf
wiederum stabilität aus dem oberkörper
aus der rückenmuskulatur mit aktivität
dabei eine komplexe übung nicht sie
bitte einmal vorzeigen genau passt gut
arme nach oben strecken hüfte schulter
breiter stand tiefe position mit dem
gesäß erreichen was hat bewegungen von
der beweglichkeit her sei es möglich ist
und drinnen ist und nach unten und nach
oben gehen
genau so ist es die leichtigkeit der
variante entsteht dann daraus wenn man
sagt man geht hat nicht ganz so tiefer
unter wird die kniebeuge definitiv
einfacher sei aber dass 30 sekunden
wirklich dort arbeitslos anstrengend ist
und entsprechend euch nicht chance dabei
zehn sekunden
dank eines wieder an 05 21 uhr los
geht's
auch bei der kniebeuge ganz wichtig die
beinachse immer zu kontrollieren ist
mein sprunggelenk quasi in kombination
mit knie- und hüftgelenk ungefähr in
einer ebene gibt da nichts nach links
weg gibt da nicht nach rechts weg ist
mein rücken gespannt bester dinge
die kontrollieren da immer wieder
abreise kunden 321 seitenaus kniebeugen
mit dem staat über kopf einmal geschafft
in die letzte übung gamer wieder auf die
matte becken heben mit der
zusatzbelastung sozusagen schaut jetzt
wie folgt aus erkennt die übung ja den
hit fast fersen sie in den boden kopf
kannst du ruhig nieder legen die arme
gibt es jetzt auf den staat drauf und da
kennt sich jetzt selber den widerstand
regulieren indem er mit den armen gegen
den staat drückt oder weniger so dass
hintern und oberschenkel heute zeit
arbeiten so viel druck baut sie mit dem
stab auf zehn sekunden gern mal wieder
an dem man noch 5 3 2 1 los geht's
becken nach oben drücken und mit den
händen gleichzeitig nach unten drücken
weiter atmen und ganz oben schwarz den
hintern offen ist dann das kleid in
einer hüft streckung hineinkommt
nach zähen sie konnten
nach drei zwei eins und zwei das aus
bitte einmal wieder aufstehen einen
durchgang mannschaft jetzt was wir uns
noch ein paar übungen außerdem ein
zweites mal machen
alle übungen gehen sie jetzt von der
zeit her nicht aus aber ab ausgewählte
machen
ich würde vorschlagen damit man wirklich
das versprechen was man anfangs gesagt
haben feuer am rücken scheiders rücken
workout manchmal gleicht das mobil ist
also die erste variante den lastzug und
die zweite des trainer gleich dazu
mit 30 sekunden belasten 30 pause
zweimal hintereinander ohne
positionswechsel
das wird richtig anstrengend für die
rückenmuskulatur bitte einmal
vorbereiten und 30 sekunden lang geht
schon los
achtet wieder auf eure heiß wir so eine
dass die gerade bleibt genau das nicht
den kopf nach vorne bewegt zu viel
halbzeit schon wieder
nach 35 sekunden sind vorbei kurz aus
lockern oder nicht das versprochen du
machst weiter geht sich das aus
na bitte dann machen wir die zweite
minute 32 sekunden nicht die zweite
minute noch fertig wahrscheinlich der
kanti olivia natürlich jetzt keine blöße
geben und muss natürlich arbeiter machen
dass wir natürlich sehr spannend dass
gleich beide weiteren supermarkt sie das
sehen sie konnten auf der übung aber
dann gleich wechseln in die rotation und
dann wird es richtig anstrengend fünf
sekunden arme strecken und oberkörper
rotation genau
zwischendrin immer wieder freundlich in
die kamera lächeln wären also dieses
olivenöl trainingseinheiten max länder
machen also zweimal am tag trainieren
wir okay wir lange dauert
durchschnittlich ein bis drei stunden
ok also da kommt er im laufe der wochen
einiges zusammen du wirkst es nur so
tiefenentspannt ist gar nicht
anstrengend für die doch sicher gehen
sie konnten fünf vier drei zwei eins und
kurz auslagern kurz durchschnaufen das
waren jetzt zwei minuten für die damen
volle belastung am rücken für euch zu
hause vielleicht auch aber zu mindestens
zwei mal 30 sekunden hat er ihnen gehabt
ok lieber welche übungen hast du nach 22
machen möchtest dir das etap sit ups da
machen wir die übung führen brauchen
auch einmal umrunden muskulatur haben
wir mit dabei staaten sieben sekunden
nach 3 21 uhr los geht's 30 sekunden
noch einmal für den bauch entweder mit
dem stab durch die beine durch fehlern
oder eben auf shimbun legen oder auf den
fuß legen beide varianten sind gut und
sicherlich anstrengend
zehn sekunden machen was noch und
ausloggen kurze kurze pause
das war richtig in der zeit ja nix
passiert die arbeitszeit ist abgedeckt
gewesen das heißt gut gemacht nicht die
eine letzte übung noch für dich was
wünscht du dann auch für ein zweites mal
machen aber die auswahl schritte okay
noch einmal in die sportart spezifik des
florett fechten es hinein mit
ausfallschritte über kopf jetzt machen
wir's aber so wir wechseln immer die
seite okay das heißt einmal aus
verschiedenen amish links einmal rechts
oder eben nach 15 sekunden die seite
wechseln geht schloss achtet auf eure
beinachse das einen schönen tiefen
schritt macht zehn sekunden noch 5 3 2 1
und auflockern stecken kann mahlzeiten
geben
super workout dankeschön fürs mitmachen
jetzt mobilisiert man noch kurz den
bereich der wirbelsäule des rückens
thema ist voll belastet haben das heißt
sätzen nieder winkels die beine an sowie
für die setup übung genau leicht
geöffnete beine und einfach einmal
kniegelenke links und rechts am boden
ablegen mobilisieren hüfte rücken machte
so cool down phase bei eurem frühen
heine oder länder und aus denen ich sage
ganz wichtig frage
ok gerne mal die beine ganz zusammen
machen wir diese bewegung noch einmal
mit geschlossenen beinen
dann ganz einmal normal locker ohne
spannung in einen crash sitz die
fußspitzen nach innen und nach außen
drehen und eine letzte übung nur zum
auslagern machen wir das heißt in
rückenlage hinlegen hände weg strecken
und mit den zehenspitzen linkes bein zu
den fingerspitzen rechtes bein und
umgekehrt hin und her einfach mal ganz
locker zum entspannen zum ausrasten zum
auflockern
drei viermal pro seite hin und her
tippen
einmal noch pro seite sehr geehrt meinen
namen ich sage danke für die mitarbeit
für das neue werk hat olivia was gibst
du den leuten damit damit sie fit aus
dem loch herauskommen
die werke videos machen rausgehen laufen
gehen frische luft schnappen und dann
wenn eines verfalls soziale sie zwar
seien alle wieder fit genau dies jetzt
noch nicht sein spätestens dann wenn sie
das programm zeit mitmachen
das war das donnerstag workout ja wir
freuen uns auf euch morgen auch wieder
zu sehen
wir sind da wir trainieren mit euch
bleibt gesund und wir freuen uns auf
euch auf morgen schönen tag noch